what's your status now you with anybody
or are you a flying single I'm with
somebody now are you in luck yeah you
are yeah definitely
uh
it'll be the best album ever if she
breaks I don't think she will you don't
do you think this is it
yeah
wow I wonder who it is someone famous or
someone not famous
someone uh that I grew up with
oh this is good you and Ed Sheeran doing
that stick as my life gets more
turbulent and I travel everywhere it's
really nice to have someone close to you
that you've known for a very long time
when you met this girl this was what
when you were in grade school or a
senior in high school or something like
that someone I've just in New Jersey
small town did she blow you off when you
were not famous and didn't give you the
time of day and she was your fantasy
girl or was she friendly with you when
times were tough she's always been very
very nice to me and ah I assume I would
assume that you know when times you know
inevitably are hard in the future
because you know what is life without uh
valleys and Peaks uh she would be there
for me as well I like what you're saying
I mean there is the Temptation when you
as big as you guys are to go out and
really you know sow your wild notes but
it could also lead to hurting a lot of
people and uh and the greatest love
songs are written from great love
so the greatest love songs are written
from great love and I'm certainly not in
the business of um hurting people will
you be popping the question
if if I do certainly the the media won't
know about it and I'll go out of that
way to make sure that they don't know
about it because it's just I don't know
it comes to him oh
oh